[MUSIC PLAYING]
MISTRAL MYERS: And I'm delighted
to welcome our two guests here
today, one of whom you
recognize from the screen
just a moment ago,
and Michael Rauch, who
is the executive producer.
So quickly, Michael
has written, produced,
and directed for numerous
television series, including
creating and producing
"Love Monkey" on CBS
as well as "Royal Pains,"
"Beautiful People," and "Life
Is Wild."
Rauch wrote and directed
the independent feature
film "In the Weeds," starring
Ellen Pompeo, Bridget Moynahan,
Molly Ringwald, and Eric
Bogosian-- is that what it is?
MICHAEL RAUCH: Bogosian, yes.
MISTRAL MYERS: There we go.
And directed and produced
the filmed version
of Bogosian's Off-Broadway
show for IFC, "Wake Up
and Smell the Coffee."
So welcome, Michael.
MICHAEL RAUCH: Thank you.
MISTRAL MYERS: Thank you so
much for being here with us.
Yes, please, some applause.
[APPLAUSE]
And now to introduce
our star, Alan.
Alan Cumming is, as
many of you know,
a wildly accomplished
performer in film,
in television, in theater--
an author, as well--
whose work includes
seven seasons
as Eli Gold on "The Good Wife,"
for which he won an Emmy.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, "Good Wife" fans in here.
ALAN CUMMING: I
didn't win an Emmy.
MISTRAL MYERS: Oh,
nominated for three.
ALAN CUMMING: Yeah, didn't win.
MISTRAL MYERS: Someone's
got your bio wrong.
ALAN CUMMING: I won an Emmy
for something else, but--
you should Google that.
[LAUGHTER]
MISTRAL MYERS:
Google got it wrong.
He's also appeared on "Sex
in the City," "Frasier,"
"The L Word"-- a
personal favorite--
"Web Therapy," and
"Tin Man," PBS' "Master
Mystery!," "The Smurfs," also.
The list really goes
on, and on, and on.
In theater, Alan has
gained stateside notoriety
for the defining role of
the Emcee in "Cabaret,"
for which you did win a Tony.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN CUMMING: Yes.
MISTRAL MYERS: A Drama Desk
award, Outer Critics Circle
award, Theater World award,
at New York Press award,
and many, many others.
ALAN CUMMING: Lots
of awards, yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS: The
list really goes on.
I had to actually cut this
down, because it would really
be too long.
We'd be sitting here forever.
Although his acting
credits do extend back
more than three decades.
ALAN CUMMING: [LAUGHS]
That was unnecessary.
[LAUGHTER]
MISTRAL MYERS: More than
a decade and a half plus.
So we're really delighted
to have both of them here
to talk about "Instinct,"
this wonderful show that you
have both created.
So, I had to start with a
burning question for you
both, which is, why did
Dr. Dylan Reinhart have
to be American?
I'm so curious.
I mean, I get the
CIA background--
ALAN CUMMING: Well,
I mean, because he
was American in the book--
MISTRAL MYERS: In the
James Patterson novel.
ALAN CUMMING: --that
it was based--
the James Patterson
book that it's based on.
I mean, he's in the CIA--
he was in the CIA.
There's not many
Scottish-- do you
mean, why is he not Scottish?
MISTRAL MYERS: Well,
I mean, I'm curious.
Was it written that way
because you really wanted
to do the American accent?
ALAN CUMMING: Play an American?
MISTRAL MYERS: Yeah.
ALAN CUMMING: No, I
don't take jobs just
so I can do an American accent.
[LAUGHTER]
I tend to just play someone,
and if they have an accent,
I try and do the one
that they should.
But I mean, he seems to
me a sort of a very much,
from my non-American-- being
born outside of America--
perspective, he seems
a very American type.
You know, he's kind of an East
Coast, kind of white bread.
He was in the CIA.
His father was in the CIA.
He's a kind of accomplished,
educated, privileged
white American.
So I think for me not to sound
like that would be wrong.
MISTRAL MYERS: Fair.
ALAN CUMMING: What do
you think, Michael Rauch?
MICHAEL RAUCH: I think that's
all correct, Alan Cumming.
ALAN CUMMING: Thank you.
MICHAEL RAUCH: I would
also say, I think--
which you may get to--
this being the first
network broadcast
hour long with a gay lead--
which is amazing.
I think to then have that person
also have an accent may be--
ALAN CUMMING: Too much.
MICHAEL RAUCH: --loading
a lot onto the character
for an American audience.
Not in a bad way, but
maybe not in the best way.
ALAN CUMMING: And I
also say that I always
think it's hilarious when
people say that someone
doesn't have an accent.
He has an American accent.
MICHAEL RAUCH: No, he doesn't.
ALAN CUMMING: Yes.
MICHAEL RAUCH: No accent.
ALAN CUMMING: It's
so funny, people
say I don't have an accent.
I'm like, you sound
like an American.
Doesn't that-- an interesting
thing about the way Americans
think about themselves.
MICHAEL RAUCH: Alan is
Scottish, playing an American.
Daniel Ings, who plays
Andy, Alan's husband,
is British, playing an American.
And Bojana, who plays
Detective Lizzie Needham,
is Serbian-Australian,
playing an American.
So we have these incredible
American accents,
and the director
yells cut, and it's
just-- it's a free for all.
There's just all these
different things going on.
Yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's fantastic.
Exactly why we
ask the questions.
See, we wanted to know all
these behind the scenes, what's
going on.
ALAN CUMMING: That's right.
MICHAEL RAUCH: Yes.
MISTRAL MYERS:
So, Michael, we're
fortunate to have you here
to be able to discuss also
the origins of the show.
So, it was based on a
book by James Patterson.
What brought you
both into wanting
to turn this into a TV series?
MICHAEL RAUCH: For
me it was two things.
One is I had never done
a crime show before.
I had a deal with CBS,
and they sent me the book.
I had never read a James
Patterson book before.
I didn't know about the
lead character being gay.
I really enjoyed the book.
I didn't want to
do a show, though,
that had nothing new in it.
And when I found out that
Dylan was, in fact, gay,
it totally changed
my perspective on
and interest in wanting
to do a show like this.
And then I heard that
Alan was interested.
And that, for me,
was, I'm in 100%.
I was and still am an
enormous fan of his,
despite his anti-Americanism.
[LAUGHTER]
And there was no one else.
You know, like, all of a
sudden, the whole thing just
jumped off the page,
and it felt like this
is a guy I want to write for.
So we had coffee and talked
about the book, and the show,
and our ideas, and
it felt very much
like we were on the same page.
MISTRAL MYERS: Did you
encounter any challenges--
and you know, we have
lots of conversations
internally about
representations of LGBTQ people
and creating narratives
around the LGBTQ experience--
did you have any
challenges navigating that?
I mean, I understand, Alan, also
that you are an EP on the show.
So, did you work
on that together?
Did you confront
any difficulties
in how it's not
always easy to write
for a very sort of
particular experience
that you may or
may not have had.
ALAN CUMMING: Well,
I think actually
what really attracted
me, one of the things
was the way that, in the book,
Dylan's gay and has a husband.
So it's not something we have
actually invented or tried
to add to it.
That was what the story was
in the James Patterson book.
And what I loved about
it in the book, which
we weren't able to do in
the show, was that the--
I wonder if they've
changed that now?
They've got the new
version of the book.
Because the book,
he was called--
I think his husband was
called Tracy, was it?
MICHAEL RAUCH: Yes.
ALAN CUMMING: And they--
because it's a
literary thing as well.
You know, you don't see it--
so they have this reveal when
he's talking about Tracy.
And then you think it's a woman,
then you realize it's a man,
so.
But I actually really
like the fact that the--
because it kind of really
annoys me that on--
certainly on network television,
if not all across the board--
if there is a gay character,
it's about their gayness.
The whole story is
about, is gay, gay, gay.
And usually in quite a sort of--
you know, they've got problems,
or they're are HIV positive, or
they're-- you know what I mean?
Not only is it
not very positive,
it's actually completely about
your sexuality, rather than,
you know.
So, I found what was really
refreshing about this--
and frankly it's something I
did not expect from a James
Patterson novel
nor a CBS series--
is a gay character, or
two gay characters, who--
and especially me--
really, his gayness is,
like, the fifth thing
that you mention in the
list of things about him.
That in itself is
really refreshing to me.
And also that you
see a relationship
that is a happy, stable
same-sex relationship.
That's unusual.
And both those things
were really important
to me, and why I
wanted to do it.
But it wasn't really
anything we did.
I mean obviously,
as ongoing, it's
something that we're
being very conscious of.
And GLAD have been very involved
in terms of helping the writers
and things like that.
And we're doing a screening
with them tomorrow.
But really, it's James
Patterson who was
the person who kind of had it.
And kind of based on, he
was roommates at college
with this guy--
who's the--
MICHAEL RAUCH: Bill?
ALAN CUMMING: Bill, who's gay.
And they've been
lifelong friends.
And I think, actually, Dylan
is the name of Bill's daughter.
So there's all these
little connections there.
He used it from
his own experience,
which is always the best
way to do things, I think.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's great.
I can speak on behalf of a lot
of members of our community
that it is
extraordinarily refreshing
to see a show in which
there is a gay male lead,
and exactly as
you say, that it's
not revolving around some issue
to do with their sexuality
or struggles with their family.
It's sort of the
entire narrative.
ALAN CUMMING: And I like the
sort of confoundingness of it,
like he drives a motorbike.
Like, a middle-aged sort of
dandy, fuddy-duddy gay guy
who drives a motorbike.
I think I love that already.
MISTRAL MYERS: Yeah, I was
going to ask, actually.
That was one of the
questions later on
is, your weaving together
so many different sort
of characteristics within
the same characters.
Nerdy, intelligent
professor who has
multiple PhDs, a slight
sort of CIA bad ass,
warm, loving husband clearly
in a stable relationship.
Those things are not
often woven together,
so how did you sort of prepare
to imagine this character
as you were getting
into it and weaving
all those pieces together?
ALAN CUMMING: Well, in a way
that's the biggest challenge.
Because most sort of
television things,
there's a one sort
of sentence hook
to what your character,
or even the whole show
is about, actually.
And so, to have so many
seemingly disparate
characteristics in one person
was both challenging, but also
attractive to me, because
potentially I could
be doing this for a long time.
And it's actually
lovely to think
there's so many areas of
him that we can explore.
And even those funny
things, like there's
an episode where we were at
this farm, because obviously
some murder's happening.
And there's a lady
comes with a chicken,
and she thinks that I've
come to pick up a chicken.
So she hands me
this live chicken,
and I go, oh, thank you.
And I start to say,
oh, it's a blah,
blah-- whatever kind it is.
And I say, oh, yes, I used
to rear these in Egypt.
And we just move on.
And I love that.
I wanted to go, when
was he in Egypt?
What was he doing
rearing chickens?
So, it's actually a
really great sort of--
do you call it in America
[INAUDIBLE],, like a lucky bag?
Do you call them that?
MICHAEL RAUCH: Yes.
ALAN CUMMING: There's
all these characteristics
in a sort of lucky bag of Dylan
that I actually look forward
to exploring.
But also it is
kind of-- you know,
that's the challenge as well,
is to try and make it like one
whole person.
But you know, I have a
lot of different facets.
MISTRAL MYERS: Yeah.
ALAN CUMMING: Do you
want to know about them?
MISTRAL MYERS: Uh, yes, please.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN CUMMING: I'm
not a natural blonde.
MISTRAL MYERS: Aw,
damn, fooled us all.
Actually, your career
has really spanned
a number of different genres--
ALAN CUMMING: I'll say.
MISTRAL MYERS: --and
you've played a variety
of different characters.
Everything from, we've seen
you in action films, "X-Men,"
"Goldeneye," to
theater and "Cabaret".
How do you choose
each of these roles?
How do you prepare for them?
What is your process
for getting into so
many different headspaces
as you're moving from--
ALAN CUMMING: Well, first
of all, I have to confess,
I really don't like
the word process.
I always say I am not a
cheese, I have no process,
when people ask me
about acting, because I
feel like that's the
antithesis of how
you do maneuver those things.
If you think about
it as a process,
then it's sort of
like a formula.
And actually, like
real people, we don't--
we are all sort of idiosyncratic
and have no kind of logic,
almost.
So, I think of acting as just
like being a child and playing.
And so obviously, you take all
the different characteristics,
and you take all the skills
that you've picked up.
It's just trying to be
someone else and meaning it.
You know, it's not
a difficult concept.
Some people are better
at it than others.
But I think of acting like being
double-jointed or something.
Some people are double-jointed--
or riding a unicycle.
Some people can do
it, some people can't.
And you can learn
to ride a unicycle,
but you might not be that good.
Anyway.
But what I do from terms in
what I'm attracted to in a role,
there's usually just one thing.
Like with this,
it was the variety
of facets to the character.
Then it was also like
when I met with Michael,
and I saw his intellect
and wit, and we really
got on, as you said.
And it's a personality
thing as well.
Sometimes it's just,
you know, I'd just
done a thing that
I shot, because it
was sort of a childhood
fantasy of mine to do it.
And other times, it's like, oh,
I'd like to go to this country,
or I'd like to work
with this person,
or I'd like to earn this money.
Do you know what I mean?
There's different
things, and you just
have to balance
everything to make
the life that works for you.
MISTRAL MYERS: I think
telling a room of Googlers
that there's no
logic or process--
we have no idea what
you're talking about.
Everything has to be written
down in a spreadsheet.
What are you talking about?
We have process docs.
ALAN CUMMING: Or you really do?
Oh, maybe I should
come and give you
a seminar on lack of process.
MISTRAL MYERS: That would
be great, would you?
ALAN CUMMING: Yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Great.
Clear your calendars.
ALAN CUMMING: I always
hated talking about acting,
but then the New
York Public Library
conned me a couple of years
ago into doing this thing,
an evening of
talking about acting.
So I called it, "I Am Not a
Cheese, I Have No Process,
Alan Cumming on Acting."
And I did.
Like this, I had
PowerPoint presentation.
Oh, it was all--
I would like-- and a
video would come on
and everything like that.
MISTRAL MYERS: Except
hopefully when you come here,
it'll be Google Slides.
ALAN CUMMING: Oh, Google Slides.
Yes, I'm all for that.
No, I loved it.
I actually liked that.
I mean, I like playing at that.
But if that's the
way you function,
I think it's good to
have order around you.
I have very good
order and really
good people, some of
whom are here today,
who help me have the
life I want to live.
But actually at
the center of it,
I think you've got to be
a little more carefree.
MISTRAL MYERS: We will try
to be carefree, of course.
We'll try.
So, for the folks
in the room who
are involved in their
own LGBTQ activism,
can you talk a little bit
about the kinds of campaigns
that you've become involved in?
I know probably some
Googlers in the room
know the work that you've done,
performing a duet with Liza
Minnelli to raise funds
for Broadway Cares, which
is in service of HIV.
ALAN CUMMING: Oh, not just.
It's actually a much
bigger, wider thing than--
I mean, Broadway Cares--
sorry to interrupt you,
but it's actually--
Broadway Cares/Equity Fights
AIDS, they kind of combined.
But actually though, they
have this breast cancer place
and helps people when
they're homeless and things.
It's a really great
sort of umbrella.
It's interesting,
actually, when you
see how organizations sort
of transmogrify according
to their circumstances.
It was started off, obviously,
as very much about a grassroots
thing about people who
are-- the theater community
was devastated by AIDS and HIV.
And then when that kind
of got more manageable,
it kind of diversified,
as it were.
And so I really think it's
a great organization though
because of that.
It's moved with the
times, and it's opened up
its ideas of who it can help.
But also, the other
things I do, like I'm
an ambassador for the
Hetrick-Martin Institute,
which is a really
good organization.
It helps a lot of homeless
LGBTQ young people.
I do a lot of things
with young people.
The Trevor Project,
I've done stuff with.
My big thing is that I
think it's bad enough,
it's hard enough being
queer in this country.
And especially right now.
I mean, I think that's
what's so amazing about--
you know, it's not good time
to be gay in this country.
Trump and this administration
are peeling back
rights in various states.
And also just by his silence,
he is condoning so much
violence and persecution against
gay people all over the place.
And so, it's more
scary to be gay now
than it has been for many,
many years in this country.
So the fact that there's going
to be a positive depiction
of some gay people
on network television
is even more special
and necessary.
So I'm actually even more
happy that that's happening.
So, I think it's hard
enough at any time
in this country to
be queer, let alone
if you are in a place of
abuse, or if you're homeless,
or if you're trying to
educate yourself to get out
of a certain situation.
So I feel a great
sort of personal
hoping to rewrite or rebalance
the world by helping when I can
and those sorts of things.
And then on broader
issues as well I've
kind of done some other stuff.
But that's really what I
feel I can be most effective.
MISTRAL MYERS: Next question
actually for both of you
on that same topic,
which is that we've both
been in the entertainment
industry for quite a while.
And for those of us who are
not familiar with that space,
we've watched, I think
collectively as a nation,
collectively as a
world, attitudes
about LGBTQ people shifting.
How have you seen
that shift working
in this space in the
entertainment industry
over the last several years?
Given that there
are ups and downs,
I'm curious how you've
seen that shift happen.
Is it easier to
put on a show that
has the first gay male lead
on network television, or?
MICHAEL RAUCH: In
terms of this show,
it could not have been easier.
CBS as a network
and CBS Studios were
100% supportive from the pitch.
Alan and I went in
to pitch the show,
and I don't we got one note
until we finished the season
about the character's sexuality
or the depiction of Dylan
and Andy and their life.
I think it's going to be
really interesting when
we start airing on
Sunday to see if there's
an audience response
about Dylan's sexuality,
and what it is.
If it's supportive, if it's not.
As Alan was saying, given the
current government's silence
and behavior towards
marginalizing people,
I don't know what to expect.
I have faith in
our audience, so I
hope that people love the
show and kind of shrug at--
they don't care that
Dylan is gay or not gay.
But I think we have worked
very hard in the writers' room,
and on set, and, as
Alan said, with GLAD,
to make sure that the
depiction of the marriage
and of the character are not
just accurate, respectful,
and authentic.
And as Alan said,
this isn't a show
about a gay CIA
working with a cop.
It's a show about an
ex-CIA guy working work
with a cop, who
happens to be gay.
And it's just a part
of the storytelling.
And just like in any crime
show or medical show,
sometimes you'd follow the lead
home and meet their partner.
And that's what we do here.
And the storytelling is
neither more dramatic
or less dramatic because of it.
So it's a long way
to your answer,
but I think in this sense,
there was no pressure at all.
And so, I think with streaming
and premium cable now,
there's so much
more representation
of all different types
of people that it's
kind of taken the
pressure off the networks
to be able to do it.
ALAN CUMMING: And I think
it's an interesting thing,
that the people who
make television and film
are, I would say, more
likely not to be supporters
of the current administration's
stance, or lack of stance,
or their silence on
certain things happening
in different states, various
rights being pulled back.
So, it's actually a funny
time when, in a way,
maybe we are not representing
a lot of the population's
opinions.
But that's because
those opinions have--
I think sometimes you have to
be a little more, you know--
you're not just a cipher.
You have to actually say, I
think this is right and good,
and we're going
to represent that,
rather than what some parts
of the population might--
negative things they
might be feeling
in terms of how the rest
of the country thinks.
So, I don't know.
I think it's really interesting.
I think it's interesting
for a network like CBS
to be launching a
show that essentially,
with this topic, is kind of
potentially controversial
or unusual in a time
where the country is kind
of going a little
backwards, in terms
of its openness and diversity.
But I think that's all
the more reason to do it,
and I'm very excited about that.
And I think whatever
happens, it's
going to be a really
interesting, telling time
for who we are.
MICHAEL RAUCH: And CBS
is, of all the networks,
I think they've taken
the most flak for--
ALAN CUMMING: Lack of diversity.
MICHAEL RAUCH: --yeah,
a lack of diversity.
So, you know, they
have been incredibly
supportive and excited
about the storytelling.
And not just with Dylan,
but the mayor, as you
guys saw, is an Indian American.
The kind of top cop is
also diverse in the show.
So, we know it's trying to
represent the real world
and that people in power
aren't just white men.
ALAN CUMMING: It's
the diversity show.
MISTRAL MYERS: It's
Well, with you both as
executive producers--
again, for those of us who
are less familiar with the ins
and outs of filming a show,
what creative control does
that give you over some of
these characters you have?
ALAN CUMMING: Oh, [INAUDIBLE]
has most creative control,
because he's in the writers'
room making them up.
MISTRAL MYERS: Perfect,
that's exactly--
MICHAEL RAUCH: Alan comes
in with a monocle on a stick
when we're not shooting.
No, this show, like
pretty much every show,
you have incredible creative
control to a certain point.
And if there are
issues, whether it's
with the studio or the network,
in terms of characters,
they'll give you notes.
And you try to adjust
the ones you agree with.
But personally, I
really collaborate
with the actors, and
especially the leads,
and especially someone as
talented and smart as Alan.
Because there's a
certain point where
their understanding of the
character is equal to you,
and sometimes
surpasses the writers,
because they're playing
this person every day.
And so, there are
times that Alan is
very respectful of the words.
But also, if he or
Bojana say, you know,
I have a problem with this, or
this doesn't seem right to me,
they're usually--
as your ego, you resist
it in the beginning,
and then five seconds later,
you realize they're right.
And you can figure out something
that works for everyone.
And it always makes
it work better.
ALAN CUMMING: And I think
it's an interesting thing that
for me, being an
executive producer,
it means that I have access
to lots of information
that I probably would never
have had just as an actor.
Which is also getting
the scripts early
and being able to
sort of make comments
earlier on than
I would have been
able to had I just gotten them
when they were the production
draft.
And that's been fascinating.
And also just seeing
cuts of it early on.
And I mean, it's
quite a lot of cuts,
so there's a lot of watching.
But for me actually,
the thing that I
like most about having a
bit more power in terms
of my position in the show,
is just actually thinking--
my two areas of
executive producers--
I really was like,
we've got to make
sure we work long, long hours
when we do this, but let's
be very respectful and
try and get people to have
some semblance of a home life.
The crew, let's try and make
sure that we don't muck about.
If we have directors who are not
prepared and are wasting time,
then we should give
them a kick in the pants
or not ask them back.
Those sorts of things are
really important to me,
because you work
incredibly hard,
and you have a great
group of people,
but you've got to make
them feel good about coming
to work and make them feel
that they're respected.
So that was very important.
And the other area
was the catering.
Because, as a vegan, I remember
having a conversation saying,
salad is not a vegan option.
It's salad.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I had a chat
with the producer,
and I remember saying, it's 20--
he said, we can bring
you food in from--
I was like, I don't want that.
It is 2017, it's New York City,
there's 150 people on the crew.
A large percentage are going
to be vegetarian or vegan.
They need to have more
than just fucking salad.
So things changed, and
it was really great.
We have vegan options.
And what's so funny about it
is that I'll be walking to set,
and there's all the
trucks and all the things,
and a teamster will come around
going, Alan, hey, morning.
I just wanted to--
thanks for the vegan options.
[LAUGHTER]
And there's all these kind
of closeted vegans coming out
of the closet now.
They've able to wave their vegan
flag because there's actually
things they can eat.
MISTRAL MYERS: You'd
think that New York would
be very friendly to vegans.
New Yorkers love vegans.
ALAN CUMMING: Yes, vegan power.
MISTRAL MYERS: Vegan power.
Does this change
your relationship
to developing the character?
Since you're saying that
you have a little more time
to think over the script,
you have a little bit more--
have you EPed on
shows previously
and, if not, then how does
that change your relationship
to actually acting?
ALAN CUMMING: Well, I
guess I haven't done--
I've, like, produced
films and things
like that that I've been in.
But the good thing about
it and how it might change
is that you actually have the
material for a longer time.
And I'm someone that I don't
really do lots of preparation,
unless it's, you know, I've
got to learn some skill.
And well, in this, I chatted
to a few former CIA operative,
because I can understand what
it's like to be a lecturer,
I can understand what
it's like to be a writer,
but I don't know many spies.
[LAUGHTER]
So it was actually really
fascinating to talk to people
and actually be able to
ask them really, sometimes,
to them, peculiar questions.
But just, I can't imagine it.
So I that was what I did.
When you have the
information for longer,
the material for
longer, for me, I
feel like it's a sort of a
seeping in kind of thing.
Like, often I just
let things ruminate.
And then when you
come to do them,
you realize you've actually
made quite strong decisions
about things without actually
having been active about that.
I feel it's like
kind of by osmosis.
So, the longer you get it,
the more ingrained it gets.
So I like that part of it,
just having more access
to the material for longer.
And then, of course, they do
rewrites and change it all.
MISTRAL MYERS: Of course.
ALAN CUMMING: Showbiz.
MISTRAL MYERS: So, speaking
of the other characters
who are in the show around
you, working with you.
Did you develop those
characters understanding
that it's based upon the
novel, but this particular show
version of those characters,
did you develop those
with those particular
actors in mind?
MICHAEL RAUCH: No, not at all.
In fact, this is the
only time, for me,
I've ever written a show knowing
who the lead was going to be.
MISTRAL MYERS: Interesting.
MICHAEL RAUCH: Which was
an incredible experience,
because it enabled me, in
terms of writing the pilot,
to write specifically to Alan.
And as a fan of his,
to how I imagined
he would be playing the role.
Every other part was
written before we
had Whoopi Goldberg, or
Bojana, or Naveen, or Sharon.
So part of what you do in
the writers' room, especially
in the first season, is, after
the first couple episodes,
you get a sense of
the actor's rhythms
and how they do certain things,
and you try to write to that.
So that as they're
discovering the characters,
you're discovering it with them.
MISTRAL MYERS: I wanted to ask
you, as I'm watching the clock
and seeing that we're going to
need to leave time for everyone
to be able to ask questions,
I wanted to quickly ask you
about your books.
So, you've written
a couple of books.
You've written "Tommy's Tale,"
"You Gotta Get Bigger Dreams,"
"Not My Father's Son,"
which became a number
one New York Times
Bestseller, congratulations.
ALAN CUMMING: Thanks.
And I've done a
kids' book as well
called "The Adventures
of Honey & Leon,"
illustrated by my husband.
MISTRAL MYERS: Interesting.
We're going to have
to check that out.
MICHAEL RAUCH: Beautifully
illustrated by your husband,
yeah.
ALAN CUMMING: And there's
a second one coming.
MISTRAL MYERS: What is
the children's book about?
ALAN CUMMING: Our dogs who died.
Well, I mean it's about
our dogs, who died.
Not our dead dogs.
MICHAEL RAUCH: It's a great
children's book, yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS: The death
part is not in the book, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN CUMMING: Although when
we were doing the press
thing for it coming out, there
were two hilarious things
that happened.
We had to go--
you know, I did all
the stuff like this.
But then I also
went to some sort
of-- there was a
thing I had to go to.
These moms influencer bloggers.
You know, moms bloggers
and things like that.
I was like, what?
And so I went to it, and
there's all these kids there,
and things.
And I just remember
thinking, oh, I
hope they don't ask
where Honey and Leon are,
the kids, because Honey
and Leon are dead.
And one of them did, and I said,
oh, they can't be here today.
Because they're dead.
[LAUGHTER]
But the other thing was, it was
an interesting kind of, for me,
a little bit of a wake up thing
about how weird I am and Grant,
my husband, is, in
terms of our lives.
Because somebody said,
where did you do this thing?
And I went, well,
it was this place,
it was sort of like a doggy
day care, but it had kids.
Someone said, so,
you mean a day care?
So my life is really
not about children.
Yeah, so I've written one.
And it's about two dogs who
live in the East Village
with their two dads.
So it's a little bit of
a queer message there.
And the dads travel
so much, and the dogs
don't like it, because
they can't protect them.
So they decide to go in
disguise and follow them
around the world.
So that's that.
And then the second one
is coming out next year.
Grant's just finishing it.
The first one is called "The
Adventures of Honey & Leon,"
and this one's called "Honey
& Leon Take the High Road,"
and they go to Scotland.
MISTRAL MYERS: Aww.
So, what was it
that compelled you
to move from acting in theater,
and in film, and in television,
to writing?
What compelled you, particularly
for those personal books
that you--
ALAN CUMMING: Well,
there's two things.
It wasn't really a move,
I've always written.
I mean, I wrote that
novel in, like, 2002.
But before that, I've written
screenplays and material
for myself.
I used to do a stand-up
comedy thing with another guy.
You know, I've written
a lot of stuff.
I've always written.
And I sort of wanted to write
a novel about how I felt.
I mean, in a way the
novel is actually
a very thinly veiled memoir
of where I was at the time.
And then, of course, I wrote the
memoir "Not My Father's Son."
I actually feel it's more of a--
it's not just about books.
It's about a thing-- like, with
also this, that movie I did,
"The Anniversary Party," and
about various other things
I've done, where
I feel when you--
and especially when
you get well know.
And there's a thing that
happens when you actually
realize that people
are as interested if,
perhaps, not more interested
in you as a person
as they are in your work.
And that's something
that you have to kind of,
I feel, own, take
responsibility for, and then
hopefully use it in a way that
can actually make your art,
your work better.
And so, I feel that there's
various things that I've
done in my career that
I feel like-- which I've
used my real life,
and I also, in a way,
played with the audience's
perception of who I am.
And those make, I think,
better connections between--
because I think it's an
interesting thing that when you
look at a screen, and
you see-- or a stage--
and you see people,
there's some people
you want to look at more.
And I think that's
another thing you
have to try and make
sense of when you're
the person being looked at.
What is it?
And I feel it's authenticity,
that's what people respond to.
So for me, my books
and things like that,
are taking that
kind of authenticity
to another genre, but
also another level
of being really, really open.
And it's actually a very
liberating thing to do,
that when you've completely
told everyone everything
there is really
to know about you
and some areas of your life.
It's actually very liberating.
And then when also with
"Not My Father's Son,"
that was incredible to
realize I had inadvertently
helped lots of people
deal with things
in their life about abuse
and stuff like that.
But really in, I
suppose, a selfish way,
it's actually about this
kind of long, several decades
thing I've got about
the work I think
works best in a certain way,
of being the most connecting
with an audience, and
the most revealing,
is work that's actually
been more about my life.
MISTRAL MYERS: I
want to make sure
that I leave enough
time to open it up.
Sorry?
MICHAEL RAUCH: You left
out one thing that he does.
MISTRAL MYERS: I did?
MICHAEL RAUCH: Yes.
Because after he writes, and
gives awards, and gets awards,
and then works 13-hour days
on set, instead of sleeping,
he goes to Club Cumming, which
is a nightclub that Alan opened
down in the East Village.
ALAN CUMMING: Yes.
And I bartend.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL RAUCH:
Bartends, and dances,
and sings till like 2:00
or 3:00 in the morning.
And then he gets picked up
at 4:00 to come back to set.
ALAN CUMMING: I was very good.
MICHAEL RAUCH: No,
you were great.
I don't know how you do it.
It's unbelievable.
ALAN CUMMING: But
I didn't go a lot.
I only went in Fridays or, you
know, if I had a morning off.
MICHAEL RAUCH: Yes,
that's what he says.
And then I'd wake
up in the morning,
and I'd go on Instagram,
and there'd shots of him,
like, with a mic in
his hand and-- yeah.
ALAN CUMMING: This is a
terrible thing to say,
but most people I
know who are actors
have been a barman, or a waiter,
or a barman, or something.
And I've never done that.
I've always just been an actor.
And I've actually secretly
yearned to be a bartender.
And now I can,
because I own a bar.
It's so great.
[LAUGHTER]
And also, I don't have to
be particularly good either,
because I just--
MICHAEL RAUCH: No, you made
me a delicious drink at--
ALAN CUMMING: See, I-- yeah.
But there's some-- there's a
thing, there's a little card,
like that, on the bar, which has
got the house special drinks.
And I-- sometimes people ask
for them, and I'm like, uh-huh,
yes, yes, sure, I
can get you that.
And after I've got to take
that thing and look at it,
look at the ingredients.
And I just do it.
But I'm kind of a sloppy
but heavyhanded barman,
so people don't mind.
MISTRAL MYERS: I feel like
that's a good reason for all
of us to go.
ALAN CUMMING: Yes, come on down.
MISTRAL MYERS: Field trip?
MICHAEL RAUCH: It's
a great club, yeah.
ALAN CUMMING: It's such fun.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's fantastic.
ALAN CUMMING:
Actually, I think it--
because I include Club
Cumming in the list of things
that I was just talking about.
I know this sounds
funny, but I do
feel it's my greatest
creative achievement.
Because I've actually
wanted a spirit and a mood.
I imagined a spirit and a
mood of a place to happen,
and it happened.
Because I kind of, like, put the
word out and kind of created it
in the ether in a way.
Obviously, I wrote things
about how I wanted it to be,
and I kind of gave interviews,
and things like that.
But it's actually-- that
spirit has really happened.
And it's a place of
people of all ages,
and genders, and sexualities.
And there's performance, and
there's dance, and it's sexy,
but it's kind of inclusive
in all sorts of ways.
And it's just kindness
is the biggest--
kindness and no judgment
are the kind of--
We did a screening of the
"Spice World," the movie.
25th anniversary of "Spice
World," the movie, in which I
have a leading role, thank you.
MISTRAL MYERS: Which
you were in, yes.
ALAN CUMMING: And so it
was a 25th anniversary
with a screening
of that, and we had
a come dressed as your favorite
Spice Girl competition.
So I was judging
it a little drunk,
and the first boy,
he was-- there
was a couple of Baby Spices.
And the first boy that did it--
and it's a tiny little stage.
And I said, so, where are you
on the Baby Spice spectrum?
And he said something mean about
the other Baby Spice person.
And the audience
were a bit [GROANS]..
And I went, oh, gosh,
I'm going to have to ask
you to leave the stage now.
And he was like, what?
And I went, that did not meet
the level of kindness that
is expected at Club Cumming,
and so you're disqualified
from the competition.
He was like, are you serious?
I went, yes, please
leave the stage.
And everyone cheered.
And then what was
great was-- well,
it wasn't great-- but he
went off stage, and fell off
and cut his knee.
[LAUGHTER]
And so Daniel, my partner
in the bar, looked up
and he went, spice karma.
Then Daniel was putting
vodka on his knee.
And this boy dressed as Baby
Spice was getting vodka,
wasting vodka on his knee.
But I just, like, that's
really important to me.
I don't want that
bad energy in my bar,
do you know what I mean?
I'm just like, no.
The staff know that, too.
If I hear-- if any of us who
run it hear of people being mean
to customers, or just
being mean in general--
and I don't mean you
need to be like a robot.
Just actually be kind, you know?
So that's very important to me.
MISTRAL MYERS: Last question
is, do you sleep ever?
ALAN CUMMING: I do, I do.
MISTRAL MYERS: Do you,
like, eat or take breaks?
ALAN CUMMING: I do, actually.
MISTRAL MYERS: Or no, it's
just work around the clock?
ALAN CUMMING: No, I'm very--
I mean, I have a lot going
on, but I'm very focused.
I think that's the thing.
I really focus on where
I am, what I'm doing.
Then I focus on fun
as well, you know.
And I'm a good napper.
I think you've got to be.
To do what I do, you've
got to be a good napper.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's key.
ALAN CUMMING: And I could
be shooting a scene,
and there'll be like
20 minutes of lighting,
I'll go up and sleep
for 15 of those minutes.
MISTRAL MYERS: Googlers
know all about that.
We have nap pods here,
and I legitimately--
ALAN CUMMING: I really would
like to see one of those.
I heard tale of your pods.
MISTRAL MYERS: Yeah, we'll
take you to see one afterwards,
definitely.
It's very important
when you've been
doing a long stretch
of coding, and you just
need a quick little.
ALAN CUMMING: I
also think I saw,
like, you've got the juice
bar, you've got the rest,
you've got all these things.
It's all just, like, to
lure you to stay here
for as long as possible.
Is that what it?
MISTRAL MYERS: Yeah, of course.
Naturally.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN CUMMING: And so, you can
actually sleep here as well.
MISTRAL MYERS: Right.
ALAN CUMMING: Is
there a launderette?
MISTRAL MYERS: Uh.
ALAN CUMMING: So, you've
got a laundrette or no?
MISTRAL MYERS: No, but I'm
sure there's one nearby.
ALAN CUMMING: And you
should have, like, a bodega.
A "bo-doogle-a."
[LAUGHTER]
I'm on a roll, Michael.
MISTRAL MYERS: So, let's
open it up to all of you
to ask questions.
Please go up to the mics
on either side of the room
so that we can capture
you and hear you properly.
You wanna line up?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for being here.
Alan, I loved your
performance back in 2013
in "Macbeth" at the Barrymore.
ALAN CUMMING: Oh, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's one of
the favorite live performances
I've seen you do,
where you played,
like, literally every
one in "Macbeth."
It was quite astounding.
I have a question about the plot
in the pilot that we just saw.
I was curious as to,
how did you decide
when and how you revealed that
you were a former CIA agent?
Because I thought it
was very interesting,
kind of the timing
of when you said it.
And it was sort of,
like, nonchalant.
But I was curious as to why
it was revealed in the pilot,
and why not, like, buried
for a later episode?
ALAN CUMMING: I guess because, I
mean-- well, that would be more
a you type of question.
I mean, my idea--
well, this is what I think,
is that it's actually
quite important in
terms of who he is,
that he's got that background
that is sort of very
different to what you might
think on the initial impression
of him.
A lot of the time-- as will come
clear as the series goes on--
a lot of the time,
Naveen's character
helps him out with getting
information that might not
be available to the NYPD.
And so his whole CIA
background becomes
kind of an issue in terms of how
he can work with Bojana, but--
MICHAEL RAUCH: It
also, I think, for him
to work with the homicide
division of NYPD,
for the audience
to know that he's
got a background
in chasing bad guys
helps make it a
lot more credible.
ALAN CUMMING: Yeah,
he's not just a--
MICHAEL RAUCH: And I don't
want to rewrite your question,
but I was really hoping
you were going to say,
you know, I saw you
do "Macbeth" in 2013,
it was really incredible.
Would you do it now, please?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we want
the Lady Macbeth soliloquy.
ALAN CUMMING: Come, you spirits
that tend on mortal thoughts.
Unsex me here, and
fill me from the top
to the toe top-full
of direst cruelty.
Um, something my blood.
Stop up the access and passage
to remorse [MUMBLES] something
compunctious nature.
Shake my fell purpose.
Come, thick night, and pall me
in the dunnest smoke of hell.
Um, blah, blah, blah.
MICHAEL RAUCH: Yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS: Yeah!
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL RAUCH: Who is
the cartoon character
over the shoulder that you did?
You know, the-- in that movie?
ALAN CUMMING: In what movie?
MICHAEL RAUCH: You
were, like, a--
because I want you to do
that now, after "Macbeth."
You did that cartoon--
you know, you, uh--
I'll remember it.
Onto the next question.
ALAN CUMMING: On my shoulder?
MICHAEL RAUCH: It was so funny.
No, no, no.
It was in a movie.
ALAN CUMMING: Oh,
the Great Gazoo.
MICHAEL RAUCH: Great Gazoo, yes.
Going to go from Lady
Macbeth to the Great Gazoo.
ALAN CUMMING: Oh, what was he--
MICHAEL RAUCH: The
range of Alan Cumming.
ALAN CUMMING: Yeah,
what was it, again?
Like, dum-dums.
It was probably dum-dums, yeah.
A range.
MISTRAL MYERS: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you both for being here.
My question is actually
very much related
to the previous one, but
I'll go one step further.
So, the pilot introduces
the lead character
as this mysterious guy,
but paradoxically we
see a lot of him.
I mean, a lot about his life.
We know that he
works for the CIA.
And we also know
that he's happily
married to a man, which I feel
like in a regular TV show,
that fact would stay
hidden for a bit longer.
So is the lead character
really that mysterious?
How much more should we
expect from the next episodes?
I must admit that I haven't
read the novels, so, I'll--
yeah.
ALAN CUMMING: One in every 17
readers in America has, but--
well, I mean, I think--
it's a pilot.
You've got to, like, say as much
as you can about the characters
to get people interested.
You know what I mean?
So he's not that mysterious.
You know a lot about him.
But that's what pilots are.
That's how you--
otherwise, you might not--
you've got to, like, fling
stuff at the audience a bit.
But the thing I think--
and I guess we do know, and in
a broad way, all these facets.
But actually, like,
you know, I was saying
that thing about the hen.
That's, for me, it's hilarious.
Like, I suddenly get
a script and go, oh,
I was once in Hong Kong
doing a blah, blah.
That part of it, I think,
there's much more in.
And there's also actually
more about his family
that you don't know yet.
The good thing about having
so many different facets, even
though you kind of show
your cards a little,
is that there's a wider or
a bigger suite to go to.
But yeah, I think
that his mystery isn't
that he's got hidden depths.
Would you say, Michael,
as the creator?
MICHAEL RAUCH: I agree.
I'd also say that, although
you in the audience know it,
the cops don't know it.
So everyone he's working
with doesn't know his past,
doesn't know he worked
for the CIA, which
obviously would change their
perception of him enormously.
So that's something that we
play with in terms of keeping
the secret from them.
And Lizzie getting
involved in that
also, because I think that
her boss, the lieutenant,
would have a very different
take on the information
they're getting
if she knew where
they were getting it from.
AUDIENCE: It was such
a privilege seeing you
in "Macbeth," and I'd love
to see you on stage again.
Is there a project that
you have coming up,
and/or is there something that
you're really eyeing to play
in the future on Broadway?
ALAN CUMMING: I
mean, we're waiting
to see if this goes again.
So that kind of makes my long
term planning rather difficult.
So if that's the case, then we'd
start shooting again in July.
But I do my concerts.
Like I'm doing a new
show called "Alan
Cumming, Legal Immigrant."
It's sort of like
a cabaret show.
My last one was called "Alan
Cumming Sings Sappy Songs."
And I'm doing a really
great thing, actually.
We're doing some shows on
tour, but then in June we're
doing two weeks
here in New York.
Because with the
last show, I began it
at the Cafe Carlyle,
which is an amazing sort
of historical cabaret
space to play at,
but it's very expensive.
And then we did Carnegie
Hall, which is also,
of course, an incredible thing.
But I was just like,
none of my friends
can afford to come and
see me doing this thing.
So I finished it in
December at Joe's Pub,
and we did a few
nights at Joe's Pub.
So now, with the new one,
with "Legal Immigrant,"
I'm doing this great
thing-- and I can't quite
believe they let me-- is
that we're doing an 8:45
show at Cafe Carlyle, and then
a midnight show at Joe's Pub
every night for two weeks.
So, I feel like I'm downtown
boy living in an uptown world.
[LAUGHTER]
So that'll be the
next thing that I'll
be performing here in New
York, and on some dates
throughout around America.
And then after the middle of
July, it's kind of all on hold.
I've got a few gigs,
actually, on weekends.
There's ones like
the Kennedy Center.
You can't turn down
MICHAEL RAUCH: You can't turn
down the Kennedy Center, no.
ALAN CUMMING: But in terms
of plays, there's nothing--
there's a couple of things I'm
sort of loosely attached to.
And there's definitely
people, like John--
talking about
"Macbeth"-- oh, you were.
John Tiffany, one
of the directors
of that, who is here
in town, actually,
is just directing that Harry
Potter play that's coming on.
I just love him.
We've done a few shows together.
He's in "The Bacchae" that I
did when I played Dionysus.
And I just really want to
do something with him again.
It's been a few
years now, and I feel
I haven't actually got
anything in the works with him.
And so I kind of miss
that sort of urgency.
But yeah, you know, it's
definitely in my periphery
that I'll be back on stage.
AUDIENCE: Well, we can't wait
to see you on a bigger stage
again.
ALAN CUMMING: Thank you.
Oh, there's one more.
MISTRAL MYERS: One more, oh.
AUDIENCE: So, this
one's for Michael.
But Alan, I have to say, you're
one of my favorite people
to follow on Instagram.
ALAN CUMMING: Oh, thanks.
AUDIENCE: And I hope to
see at Club Cummings.
ALAN CUMMING: Cumming,
Cumming, -ming, -ing, -ing.
AUDIENCE: Oh, Cumming.
Oh.
So, in terms of writing
for a character where
you know who the actor is,
what would you say are some
of the cool parts of
that, and anything
you need to be mindful of?
MICHAEL RAUCH: I'll
answer the second part.
I think being
mindful of not trying
to repeat what you've
seen him do before
and what you've fallen in
love with the actor doing,
so you're not just going
down the easy route.
But, you know, when I write,
I don't think of actors.
So I just create a
character and follow it.
But to be able to
have someone in mind,
and visualize them, and have an
idea of what their rhythm is.
And, I mean, Alan was talking
about not having a process,
and I respect that 100%.
But someone with
that type of talent,
there is a magic that happens.
And you watch them
because there's
something going on that
makes you need to watch them.
And Alan has that.
So, to be able write a
character and imagine them
in a bespoke tweed suit
with a pocket square,
and at the same
time pull out a gun,
I don't think there's a lot of
people who could pull that off.
So, I don't know
if I would have had
the confidence to do that if
I didn't know it was Alan.
I imagine Alan
dressed like that.
In fact, we had this
Christmas party at CBS
that we had to-- we
didn't have to go to,
but you had to go to it.
ALAN CUMMING: You had to.
MICHAEL RAUCH: And we happened
to be shooting two blocks away
from the party so that we could
get the actors to the party.
So, we shooting
the finale, and it
was really important to get
there at a certain time.
And I just said to Alan--
he wrapped-- I was, like,
we're still shooting.
I was like, listen, can
we get there quickly,
can you just go
in your wardrobe.
You know, he's wearing
this beautiful suit
and these great shoes.
And he was like, I'd rather
just get in my clothes.
I was like, what's
the difference,
you're in this beautiful suit.
And he was like, let
me just quickly change.
So he quickly changes.
And all of a sudden, it's a
totally different human being.
And I forgot that that was Alan.
You know, with his spiky
hair, and a t-shirt,
and these great pants.
And so, I imagined the other
guy, and Alan became that guy.
And so it just became a
much more enjoyable way
to think about it.
Do you write?
AUDIENCE: No, no.
I'm just interested.
MICHAEL RAUCH: You
know, you're just
trying to figure out
when you're coming up
with a character all these
little different parts of them.
And when you have a
head start, especially
this type of head start, it
makes it much more enjoyable.
ALAN CUMMING: And I think it's
funny as well that I feel--
obviously, I sound and look
very different to the person
you saw earlier on the screen.
And we haven't shot it, we
were finished in December.
So it's like a couple of months
now, a few months away from it.
I've done other
things in between.
That it's actually crazy-- like,
just today, doing talk shows,
they play a little
clips of the show.
And I'm like, oh,
yeah, that's funny.
Oh, I forgot about that.
And actually, when you're
in it, it's so easy,
and kind of you're
just that person,
and you know that you
have all these traits,
and you have all these things.
And actually standing
apart from it,
it's sort of, you look back
and think, I don't-- oh,
I can't remember
what that was like.
But the great thing about
this character, I feel,
is that there's a multitude
of different layers.
It's actually something
I'm really looking forward
to going back to explore more.
I think there's a lot of
stuff that we could do.
And that's really
exciting to me, to go back
and try and do that.
MICHAEL RAUCH: He's
very stuffy in the show.
And it just brings
so much comedy
to see him be stuffy
and unhappy about when
things don't go his way.
And it's so unlike
how he is in real life
that you just want to
keep writing to it,
because it's so absurd to
get to see him do that.
ALAN CUMMING: And
then when we dance--
we have this thing
where one of the--
there's probably about three
cameras all going at once.
And they have the dolly.
You know, the thing
they'd push like that.
And they have these
little, you know,
like Alexa-- oh, what's
the Google version?
MISTRAL MYERS: Google Home.
ALAN CUMMING: What?
ALAN CUMMING: Google Hum?
MISTRAL MYERS: Google Home.
ALAN CUMMING: Home, oh I see.
Google Hum.
Bit of a Google Hum.
Well, anyway, imagine a
Google Home on the dolly.
And in between takes,
we would dance.
Like, just dance like crazy.
The whole crew.
Sometimes, to keep warm.
Just on the stages,
that would be our thing,
we'd just be like mm-hmm.
And you can tell different
directors who are coming
in were like, what's going on?
They'd come up to
give me a note,
and I'm like,
uh-huh, yeah, what?
Oh, sure.
Yeah, I'll do that.
Yeah, right, OK.
And it was a really great
thing, because also I
loved how many people
would post things of it.
To see me and Bojana, in the
police station, for example,
me dressed in my sort
of fuddy-duddy way
rocking out to, like,
Black Box from, like, 1998.
It's really fun.
And I think that's the thing.
You've got to try
and be both things.
Go straight for that character,
but also retain your own self.
And again, that's also
the thing but making
the crew feel that
everyone joins,
and everyone does
the same thing,
and everyone feels good
about coming to work.
Because there's not
many shoots I've
been on where the leading
actor kind of demands
that you dance between takes.
Or you're fired!
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I need to ask you
about "The Good Wife."
So, big fan of the series,
and, of course, Eli.
I want to ask you how you
feel about the show ending,
and also will we see
Eli on the spin-off?
Because I know his
daughter's there, Melissa.
But will we see you
in the second season?
ALAN CUMMING: Ehm,
no, is the answer.
There was talk of it, but some
technical issues happened.
See, I feel like--
I think there's a thing in
America where people aren't
good about ending things.
And I think it's all about
sort of-- when something's
a success, you just
whip it until it falls--
or until you jump the shark,
that's what you call it,
doesn't it?
So I felt like when
"The Good Wife" ended,
I thought it was the
perfect time for it to end.
I thought the arc of
the story was great.
It was the creators
who were still
working on the show who did that
and ended it how they wanted.
It wasn't kind of
just, you know--
in a funny way, I feel
like on television,
especially on network
television, what you're
doing is just making
stuff to fill up
the gaps between
the commercials.
So when you have a chance
to actually really craft
something, I think part of the
craft is to kill it as well.
Or to end it.
Maybe kill is the wrong word.
So I was actually really glad
that "The Good Wife" finished.
I was ready to go as well.
I was going to leave,
and then they told me
they were ending it, so I
stayed for the last season.
So that was great.
But then when this
spin-off thing came up,
"The Good Fight,"
and I knew they
were going to do that, I
was like, oh, that's nice.
But then when we were shooting
our show, a lot of the people
were in the same sound stage,
and some of the same crew
had been working on it.
I was like, oh, so
what's happening?
Oh, really?
Oh.
Well, my daughter's in it.
Did they mention me ever?
Did they mention Eli?
It was kind of funny.
It got me all going again.
And actually it'd be quite
funny to go back and do Eli.
MISTRAL MYERS: All right.
Well, in our last minute
or two, without giving away
too many spoilers,
can you just let
us know what we should
expect from the upcoming
season of "Instinct"?
ALAN CUMMING: At
one point, I shoot
a glass of poisoned iced tea
out of Whoopi Goldberg's hand,
thereby saving her life.
[LAUGHTER]
How is that?
MISTRAL MYERS: That is the
perfect way to end this.
I can't wait to see it.
ALAN CUMMING:
That's basically it.
MISTRAL MYERS: Please
give everyone a round
of applause for our two guests.
[APPLAUSE]